you've lived your whole life in a world
that completely hates and mistreats you
and now you've been given Godlike Powers
what do you do you'll be forced to
battle other girls with horrifying
Powers as well and on top of that you'll
be forced to stop god-like beings hell
bent on destroying the entire world and
nobody here is your friend I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the magical
girl gods in magical girl sight this
girl is going to be forced to battle an
incoming God sent to destroy the world
Aya here is a school girl that hates
life and herself Trouble Follows her
daily and she is losing the will to live
after school she heads home to a family
that doesn't care about her and she is
overshadowed by her High achieving older
brother and this glass is wearing
brothers named kanime he hates Aya and
is secretly a psycho and will try to
kill Aya before she knows it later that
night she lies in bed beaten to a pulp
when her laptop screen turns on and a
creepy Melody begins playing shikash
reads the words on the screen the
magical girl website this Sinister girl
that appears on the screen and offers to
give Aya special powers and change her
unfortunate life forever she tells her
that the website will soon deliver her a
magical wand but she gets creeped out
and closes the laptop shut the next day
at school she discovers a special
present inside her locker and realizes
that it's the magical wand along with a
note stating that Aya is now officially
a magical girl she thinks it's a joke
but doesn't realize that this wand and
many others like it will cause deaths
all over the world later that day
trouble at school becomes too much and
she gets chased outside by these awful
girls in this douchebag hiding behind
this car she desperately tries to
silence her terrified tears but gets
discovered knowing what horrifying Faith
awaits her if she doesn't do something
she whips out her magical wand and
instantly fires it activating her powers
and sealing her fate the man and the
Mean Girl disappear from view but Aya
suddenly hears the bloody sounds of
crushed bodies and Loud screams coming
from the nearby train tracks looking on
from a distance she then realizes that
she just murdered two of her classmates
and blood begins to run from her eyes
and someone watches her from the
distance she runs home and tries to find
out more information about what the hell
is going on but discovers that the
magical website doesn't exist and goes
into a fitful sleep terrified about what
is coming her way the next day at school
a friend of the dead girl named Serena
confronts Aya and she thinks that
somehow she's responsible for her
friend's death in an act of Vengeance
she tries to surgically tear her cheeks
off but that's when everything around
them freezes and suddenly the same girl
from yesterday appears and introduces
herself as yatsamura she reveals that
she's done the impossible and has
stopped time all around them she is a
magical girl too and this is her power
the ability to control time without
hesitation she grabs the knife and slits
Arena's throat right in front of aisle
telling her that they don't have time to
mess around because she needs to tell
her all about the magical girl website
that apparently does exist yatsamura
gets Aya out of there and then unfreeze
his time on pausing Serena's terrifying
accident and tells her that her wand has
the power of instant teleportation and
with this power she should use it to
cause harm to anyone that tries to
threaten her again heading back to her
house they run into Aya's Brotherhood no
but thankfully yatsamura can sense the
glasses guy energy coming from this
weirdo and tells Ayah that she knows
that her brother is a creep but that's
when Aya gets informed of even more bad
news she is warned that each time they
use their magical power their life force
drains and the tattoo that all magical
girls get represent their life points
and once it runs out they die okay Liz
what these girls have just made it to
school they made a heck of a lot more
terrifying and now we're gonna have to
figure out the situation listen if I was
IO I would first assume that Sans
yatsumura is a magical girl and the
process to becoming a magical girl is
through a website and not some one punch
man workout routine I think it would be
safe to assume that there are more
magical girls out there since the uh
well recruitment process is uh kind of
easy knowing that there are others out
there like me I would first post on
Reddit in Japan calling out to any other
magical girls out there to hit me back
send me a message hopefully someone will
get back to me and during all of that I
would try to figure out the full extent
of my powers and my weaknesses by
analyzing my tattoo yatsamura in this
regard is an idiot she earlier told us
to use our powers to rid the world of
evil but in doing this we'll eventually
run out of life force and die so maybe
we shouldn't rely on our powers entirely
if these tattoos you could say Huff bar
goes down each time we use our powers I
would try to measure how much this
tattoo would go down or disappear each
time we blasted our wand once I figured
that risky part out it will
subconsciously Force us into relying
more on our intellect and tactics and
other tools that we can use that are at
our disposal instead of using our powers
and this is why I would grab a knife for
one turn on YouTube and begin to learn
some knife as this will allow me to
become more competent in using some sort
of ranged weapon since guns in Japan are
hard as hell to get it will likely give
us an edge literally because when we
eventually meet more magical girls
they're all likely going to rely on
their powers because what Aya is facing
right now is seriously messed up and I
didn't even include the bit of the story
where she made friends with a stray cat
that got brutally murdered by one of the
Mean Girls yeah it's really awful
yatsamura warns Aya that there are more
magical girls out there and they are all
more violent than anyone can imagine and
tells her that before she found her she
was working with another magical girl
who recently went missing they were
working together to stop a merger known
as the magic Hunter this person had been
stealing all the wands of the magical
girls around town and this killer has
now gotten to her friends as well or so
she thinks yatsamura asks Aya for her
help and stopping this killer and
getting to the bottom of the magical
girl website mystery since they've all
now joined this strange Club they'll now
likely be targeted soon unless they do
something the next day Aya walks back
home from school when she comes across a
strange girl who is in need of her help
she asks Aya if she wouldn't mind dying
right now and she activates her magic
powers and yatsumura in the distance
freezes time but realizes then something
terrible that girl is a magical girl too
and now has Aya trapped inside of some
kind of magic force field unable to do
anything yatsamura discovers that this
person is the magical serial killer the
killer begins to bleed and tells Aya to
hand her want over Aya tries to escape
but she tells her that this box is
unaffected by the outside world and
There Is No Escape
oh
this is terrifying because we know that
this person has killed before in the
past many times and this means that
they're probably likely not going to
hesitate to kill Aya if she steps out of
line at all but there are a few ways
that we can try to get out of this
listen Okay first what we need to do is
to close the gap between her and Aya
because the killer has a long-ranged
weapon right if I was Aya I would first
use the Killer's preconceived view of us
to our advantage and would first
collapse to the floor in sadness looking
as harmless as hell and the killer
judging from that react alone because
she seems to be the type to really gloat
and enjoy the murdering process to its
fullest she'll think I'm weak I'm
pathetic so she'll likely Waltz ride on
over to get up close and personal and
absorb all my juicy juicy horrific
suffering but once the gap between her
and us is closed I would utilize my
Japanese school bag here as a serious
weapon because I'm not even kidding this
thing is heavier than it looks
classrooms in Japan sometimes don't let
children keep textbooks and notebooks
after class which means it's common for
kids to come and go with all the
necessary class items that they need
every day and this is when makes the
average weight of a Japanese school bag
around 4 kilograms which means that once
the distance is closed I'm going to use
my heavy ass backpack and knock the
out of her with it once she is knocked
down I would then try to go over her
eyes and stab big huge holes in those
things and take her out and see how easy
it is to shoot off your wizard powers
like Gandalf without having any eyes
you're not going to be able to see
from there on she would be forced to
deactivate the force field and we'd be
scot-free and she'd be dead or blind the
killer tries to smash Aya's head in but
she Dodges and yatsamura begs Aya to use
her weapon and so she does firing her
weapon and deactivating the force field
yatsumura tells Aya that she can
teleport someone wherever she wants as
long as she imagines it in her mind
finding the killer they later capture
her but yatsumura realizes something
terrifying she knows who the identity of
this killer is and reveals that the
magical girl killer is actually her
friend that recently went missing chioi
she used a magic wand and this camera to
change her identity and to lure Aya and
out of options chioi then breaks down
and then says the that she had to kill
all those girls because of something
horrifying that is headed their way if
she doesn't she won't survive till the
end concerned yatsamura asks what the
hell is she talking about shioi
confesses that she needs to find as many
wands as she can in order to give it to
a powerful God that will soon arrive on
Earth known as The Tempest she
discovered this while investigating the
magical girl website and met with one of
the site's administrators to find out
more the same administrator that gave
Aya her powers and that's when she
starts coughing up blood and suddenly
goes into shock forcing these two girls
to quickly call an ambulance later at
the hospital they find out more bad news
she always body has taken on too much
internal damage and the girls suspect
that it's because of all the wants that
she's been using yatsamura tells Aya
that they need to figure out what more
she only knows and they need to find out
a way to wake her up and Aya comes up
with a brilliant idea and thinks that
there might be another magical girl out
there who has the power to heal her with
magic taking shioi's murder notebook
that contains the pictures of all the
nameless magical girls out there looking
through it they recognize one face this
girl who goes by the name nishimin and
she is an international pop star they
find out that she's putting on a concert
and so they head on over there and
pretend to be her biggest fans and at
that moment the two combined their
powers and freeze time and teleport them
and niji mean a way to more private
location here they tell her that they
are magical girls and confront nishimim
about her powers but this pop star gets
way too excited and tells him that she's
always wanted to meet others like her oh
that's so great I'm really scared about
what's gonna happen next I had then
tells her that they're looking for a
magical girl that can help get her
friend out of a coma but then suddenly
some of niji means managers arrive and
carry her back to her concert she yells
at these two to come meet her at her
apartment later tonight to discuss
things further wasting little time they
eagerly rush over to her apartment that
night but yatsumura thinks that
something fishy is going on niji mean
greets them and takes them up to her
place where she has all of these Butlers
serving her that's when this pop star
reveals her want it's her underwear and
it has the power of mind control and
these two realize how powerful this girl
really is yatsamura asks her if she has
ever met any other magical Girls before
and that was her biggest mistake nijibin
begins to get serious and mentions that
she was once close friends with another
girl like her but that girl ended up
getting murdered right in front of her
by a sadistic killer she starts to go
into deeper into her thoughts and very
quickly turns full cycle and draws the
face of the murderer on this paper and
these two quickly realize who exactly
she's talking about it's shioi okay
we've just discovered that these magical
girls are more nuts than we thought
which means we have to behave with
Extreme Caution because as long as you
know they're insane but there is
something that I have noticed due to
easy means power it's likely that she
used it to help her out in her career
and is clearly using it in her personal
life 24 7 as we can see but just like
her it's noted that shioi also kept
using all the other magical wants that
she stole and also exhibited signs that
she was crazy and these two using their
powers at such levels and being batshit
crazy is no coincidence and this makes
me think that using magic in excess or
on a consistent basis can actually cause
brain damage in a magical girl and if
you think about why these girls were
chosen to become magical girls then it
makes it pretty obvious that they are
just one bad day away from going insane
just about any ordinary person can slip
into madness and that means even if we
can't use nishamin we could still use
her powers to save shioi but letting
nishimin continue to use her powers like
this from here on out is out of the
question because she is too unstable and
will become completely useless because
she will be dead from overusing her
powers because of this I'm going to do
everything I can to become friends with
her and arrange another meeting the next
chance I get once mating with her I
would then quickly knock her out from
behind then disarm her uh Magic uh wand
and then put it on myself then I would
broadcast onto live TV and ask if all
the other magical girls would be willing
to come meet me at Nisha means apartment
because it's more safe for me then and
in this way I could shortcut everything
and have them come to me mean all the
while the rest of the country wouldn't
know what the heck a magical girl even
was and from here we could surely find
someone with magical powers because
these two here are making things way
more complicated than they really need
to be realizing that they can't use her
anymore yatsamura makes an excuse for
her and Aya to leave the two returned to
the hospital to discuss how to find more
magical girls since they obviously can't
use nijamin but they don't realize that
someone is listening into their
conversation it's ayas mean classmate
Serena she's alive and recovering from
her wounds in the same hospital and she
accidentally overhears them talking
about the magical girl website whoops
and their powers and their plans to heal
shioi waiting for them to leave she
sneaks in tishioi's room but discovers
this strange little girl who she doesn't
realize is actually the Magica girls
website administrator Nana she tells the
confused Serena here that chiyoi has
been disqualified from being a magical
girl but thanks Serena will make the
perfect victim instead Nana feels Serena
in on the magical girls site and reveals
that Aya and yatsamura are magical girls
too and she tells Serena that she could
exact revenge on those two if she wanted
and tells her that she told shioi to
collect different wands for her before
she went into a coma and now she needs a
new magical Hunter to help her out with
this task offering Serena her powerful
wand this yo-yo she tells her to go make
Aya and yatsamura pay and bring their
wands to her when she's done and the
administrator Chuckles sinisterly the
next day in class
Aya realizes yatsumura isn't there and
she's never late to class and just then
her school teacher announces that
someone new will be joining their class
today pop star niji mean enters the room
and all the kids go wild she later tells
Aya that she's quit her pop star career
to focus on finding her friend's killer
in order to gut her like a fish and is
now joined Aya's school because uh Well
friendship wow that's terrifying I tries
not to panic and to think of a planet so
nijimane doesn't find out where shioi
really is quickly changing topic Aya
states that she'll go after class to go
check out yatsamura since well she
didn't show up for class today and tells
her that she'll catch up with her later
not realizing that Serena has followed
them and is listening in again after
school I head to yatsumura's house but
finds the door unlocked quickly
realizing that something is wrong she
cautiously enters but finds a man
tortured right in front of her and
yatsamura passed out nearby she rushes
over to check her out and realizes that
she's been using too much of her magic
recently and is on the brink of death
spilling the beans she confesses to Aya
that she was trying to avenge her
family's death by torturing their killer
this man and this is why she became a
magical girl in the first place and
that's when Serena enters chuckling and
reveals a huge plot twist she tells them
that she overheard everything that these
two have been planning and she's told
nijimin where she always being kept in a
matter of seconds their only hope to
figuring out the magical girl website
will be slaughtered along with these two
here okay the situation was unexpected
and means that we don't have time to
mess around it makes no sense why
yatsumura didn't have any protection at
her very own apartment especially when
she is not only keeping a hostage who
she clearly doesn't want to let Escape
but also since she's a magical girl
being caught off guard in any situation
could mean instant death her lazy
preparation means that we need to save
the day so annoying if I was Aya I would
realize that Sabrina here revealing her
magic weapon was in fact her biggest
mistake because we can now directly
Target it since we know that on average
the string of a yo-yo is around 110
centimeters because everybody knows that
information oh by the way that's 43.3
inches I would quickly leave yatamura
right where she is fall backing away to
the end of the room ensuring that we
would technically be out of range for
Serena's weapon and would be safe for
what comes next from here I would rely
on Serena's fiery and very aggressive
personality and taunt her and make her
attack us as quickly as possible and not
think once she tries to strike us I
would use my teleportation wand and
create a portal right in front of us
with the second exit portal appearing
right behind Serena's back this would
ensure that sereno's lethal go blade
would end up killing her instead of us
in one swoop genius I love it besides in
reality this move isn't really that hard
if any of you have ever played the game
portal Serena charges at these two
swiftly killing yatsamura's hostage
telling Aya that there only needs to be
one magical girl left standing in order
to collect all the wands Shea forces Aya
to realize that she is the new magical
Hunter but Serena gets a call mid-fight
from nishimina at the hospital and she
complains to her that she can't kill
shioi because she is being protected by
some sort of magic trap on her deathbed
yatsumura says that she's not letting
shioli die until they get some answers
about the Tempest and what does Serena
do she laughs and wishes them a good
journey down to Hell while that's when
Aya finally grows a freaking pair of
cojones and fires her wand back at her
the two go at it in an epic magic battle
blasting rounds and losing Precious
Years off of their life and the building
starts to collapse as Ayah last minute
uses her extra wand to create a force
field around her and yatsumura and just
then she does the unthinkable she also
uses her magic to save Serena's life Wow
that is a huge mistake minutes later
though help arrives as this blue
Heritage detective gets out and finds
Aya and yatsamura safe and sound and
they get rushed to the hospital
elsewhere though nijamin has gone
absolutely nuts and thinks Aya and
yatsamura betrayed her wanting Revenge
she heads over to Aya's house to rip out
her sweet guts but runs into her brother
and she is shocked because he is so damn
hot the brother lets her in and tells
her that Aya isn't home but recognizes
her as the famous pop star and he asks
how her and Aya met and doesn't believe
that his piece of trash sister could be
friends with the Superstar and thinks
Nigerian is lying to him searching on
Aya's computer before he thinks that Aya
and her new friends are in fact magical
girls whatever that means meanwhile
across the table nijamin is losing her
mind over how hot brother glasses guy
here is and so she decides to spare
Aya's life and only kill shioi instead
and then she happily leaves Aya's house
not realizing that her brother has now
just made her his new Target back at the
hospital where all the girls are
recovering this stranger wearing an eye
patch sneaks into Joey's room and
awakens her from a deep coma with magic
Shoei wakes up in shock and this girl
introduces herself as kosame and tells
her that she and a group of magical
girls brought her back because they want
to find out what she knows about the
Tempest sure still lost for words can't
help but notice kosamace magical tattoo
being different than the rest of the
magical girls but kosame tells her the
reason why there are several different
magical girl websites and many different
administrators she is a part of another
magical girl group but all of them will
soon need to band together if they want
to survive because they think all the
administrators are hiding something
moments later back in Iowa's room her
and yatsamura suddenly wake up but
they're shocked when they say shiori
standing right in front of them but she
updates them on what's going on and what
eye patch girl kosame here told her the
reason the magical girls site exists is
to help bring back and evil God known as
The Tempest a God that feeds off of
negative energy and the negative energy
is collected inside of everyone's
magical wands the girl who gathers the
most wants and delivers it to the
Tempest when he arrives will be spared
from Extinction Aya and yatsamura and
she only realized that everyone here has
just been played this whole time and
knowing this she always offers these two
a truce and everyone decides to join
forces kosame also informs them that
more magical girls around the country
have started to band together as well
but the site administrators never
intended for any of them to find out
this information and those that have
have recently died knowing that it won't
be long before they are killed for
breaking the rules kosame says that the
need to capture a site administrator as
soon as possible so they can find out
more information about the end of the
world from them the rest of the girls
think they now know what to expect
becauseame first warns them that as
magical girls they will never reach old
age and will likely die in the near
future because of the impact their
powers have on their bodies and they
have to use their powers otherwise
they'd have no shot at this and they
might even very well die the next day
even then knowing the risks they all
accept their fate and so kosame gives
everyone here the location of where to
meet to the rest of her team tomorrow
the next day at school Aya sits in class
with an easy mean and then the teacher
announces that they're getting another
new student and I as ice fill up with
horror as she sees who it is ichioi and
she stares at niji mean who's shocked
with lethal excitement and she is about
to use her powers when yatsumura tackles
her and these two work together to
disable her powers well if you know what
I mean wink wink and then they get a
text from kosame to meet them at the
park heading there they tried to make
nishamin feel better about what they're
doing by telling her their plan to stop
the end of the world from happening but
nijimin says that she will only help if
she can kill shioi now stuck with a big
problem they meet up with shoi and the
rest of them at the park but nishimi
starts freaking out again and yatsumura
tells Nisha mean that she's hidden her
magical underwear until she calms down
and that's when the group of the other
magical girls show up and they all
introduce each other and their powers
black hair girl Makari Kyo Haru and red
hair girl kosame reveals the plans to
kidnap the site administrator but
yatsumura shioi and Aya mentioned that
they've all lost their wands yesterday
during the collapse at the buildings so
they need to find their stuff first
before they go into battle and the new
magical girls offer them their
protection in the meantime and they use
kyoharu's mind-reading powers here to
update everyone when a site
administrator shows up meanwhile though
Serena is off on her own adventure
collecting more magical wands and then
she finally goes to meet with her
sighted ministrator but then has a
change of heart and tells her that she
won't hand over all of her wands until
she kills Aya and yatsamura annoyed Nana
here tells her that as long as she does
as she's told and doesn't Snoop around
she won't be killed that night Aya finds
out from kyohuru that thanks to her mind
reading powers she's discovered that
yatsumura is secretly on the brink of
death and can't use her magic too many
more times otherwise she'll die because
of this Aya organizes a typical anime
beach trip the next day with all the
magical girls to go enjoy life one more
time before they all die they celebrate
together and I have become super duper
best friends with yatsumur in just 5
anime seconds at its own oh so cute but
at the end of the day they return to
their lockers and find out that someone
has stolen niji means wand but Tunisia
mean secretly realizes that the thief
must be her new secret boyfriend glasses
guy because uh oops she recently told
him everything and said that he wants
her to be safe but she doesn't share
this information with the group and has
somehow no idea that she has created the
most horrifying serial killer in
existence the girls began searching for
Nisha means wand when Aya comes across
her brother down at the beach and sees
him wearing nishimi's powerful panties
and he uses it to murder this random
dude watching in shock Aya hides before
he can see her and doesn't tell the
other girls about what she just saw and
then they head back to black hair girl's
place in order to figure out their next
step holy crap we are in so much trouble
because just like us Reddit thinks that
this glasses guy is seriously scary and
now makes me 100 certain that anyone
wearing glasses is bound to be a freak
deep down in there somewhere but what I
did just now demonstrates a bigger
problem with this group and it has to do
with their maturity because this is
going to severely hinder their ability
to save the world and themselves if I
was leading this group I would have from
the very beginning vetted all of the
magical girls here I just met them I'm
not gonna bond with them over one beach
trip I would have looked into all of
their families because we are still
children after all and according to
science around the age of 12 is when
children will be the easiest to be
influenced and since we're all still
children this means that statistically
most of us will still have been highly
influenced by our families to begin with
and any member here with a family member
still alive means that if worse came to
worse this magical girl member would
still have a decent chance to choose to
be loyal to their family over the
magical girl group and that is a problem
as a group we are only as strong as our
weakest link By ignoring the fact that
we're all mentally unstable in general
because that's why we're magical girls I
would have placed special watch over
members of the group that demonstrated
signs of instability with their psyche
like Ayah yasamura clearly knew that her
family was messed up and that her
brother was Pure Evil and if she was
smarter she could have easily figured
out what Aya was up to on the bus back
home kyoharu accidentally reads Aya's
thoughts and discovers the secret about
her brother the police then investigate
the murder on the beach and the same
blue hair guy from earlier shows up he
discovers that this victim was a fan
obsessed with nishimi and finds a photo
of her in his pocket the girls head back
to black hair girl's house while nijamin
heads home to find a glasses guy she
meets up with him and thinks that he's
taking her panties because he wants to
protect her what an idiot he begins to
treat her like a dog makes her regret
everything he tells her that he has no
use for her anymore and is about to use
his magic powers to murder her when red
hair grows suddenly out of nowhere
dashes in and knocks him down and
reveals that Kyo Haru told her about
glasses guy earlier and she's here to
stop him but then she violently gets
choked by nishit mean and discovers that
glasses guy here gave her orders earlier
to protect him at all costs and now she
is completely under his spell helpless
he uses his magic to command red hair
girl to go kill the rest of the magical
girls using her super speed she dashes
right towards Kyo Haru before she even
has a chance to act and rips through her
chest and red hair girl's spell wears
off losing blood they all quickly head
back to black hair girl's house and
inform everyone that Kyo hero needs help
and that daya's brother glasses guy is
headed their way the girls quickly tried
to rush and heal her and Aya finally
confesses that her brother stole the
panties the rest of the girls rightly
become furious at her for keeping such a
secret and suspect that nishamin tried
to resolve this issue herself as well
and that's when glasses guy shows up
ready to kill the girls tried to stop
him but are too late and are commanded
to kneel down before him and not move a
muscle and that's when he thinks Aya for
helping him become a God and he kicks
her in the face and that's when nishimen
enters the room and the girls are
shocked to find that she is now
completely under his control and she
gets ordered to steal all of their wands
but Kyo Haru Pele alive uses her mind
reading powers to break niji means spell
and secretly tells her to stop glasses
guy when she gets the chance horrified
at what she's done nishimi quickly loses
it and rushes in to attack glasses guy
without thinking like an idiot and then
gets stabbed by him and falls to the
floor and the rest of the girls are
forced to watch using the last bit of
her strength she manages to stab glasses
guy in the throat and he starts spewing
blood he panics and tries to reach for
the magic wand that can heal his
injuries but suddenly something stops
him this invisible person as the bomb
goes off the room and everybody passes
out later the girls wake up and discover
that glasses guy has gone missing but
also find that Nisha mean here has
already taken her first class flight
Straight to Hell and everybody starts
weeping the next day the world is
informed of the pop star's death and
some of the girls wonder who saved them
and why they stole their wands now
without weapons they wonder how they
will take on the terrifying
administrators elsewhere though Aya
finally breaks out of her depression
from nigerian's death and tries to look
for her in yasimura's wands back where
they battled Serena but that's when
Serena shows up from behind enter and
holds her up at gunpoint that afternoon
the girls joined the rest of the country
and they show up to nishamin's funeral
but Aya shows up in haste and magically
teleports them all without explanation
and right then a terrifying bomb goes
off at the funeral and teleported to a
safe location the girls are shocked to
see Aya with her wand and it's pointed
right at them back at the now destroyed
funeral Nana sits to the middle of it
all and Chuckles and then a policeman
shows up it's blue haired guy and Nana
tells him that if he did his job then
she wanted to head to kill the girls
blue hair guy says that he's killed
glasses guy as per orders and Nana
orders him to retrieve the girl's wands
and the rubble and then he disappears
back at the girls Safe House Aya tells
him what she's found out the site
administrators just tried to have them
killed and tells them that from now on
she will be fighting the bad guys
herself along with Serena she shows up
and reveals that she switched sides
since I convinced her to now be a good
person and tells them that she has all
of their magical wands and Aya tells the
girls that she will handle the fight
from now on and will sacrifice herself
to save everyone but yatsumura pimp
slapped the out of her and tells
her that they're all a team and they
knew what they signed up for and Serena
thinks that all of this cuteness is
super corny but I have finally agrees to
let everyone join in and everybody takes
back their wands and they suit up or
wound up for battle Serena tells them
what she knows about Tanana and the
administrators different administrators
have different jurisdictions and that
they should attack one that isn't a part
of any of their jurisdictions this way
that administrator won't know their full
powers and their capabilities using
their Tech skills they track down
someone online who's about to become a
new magical girl staking out her house
and her school and they wait for an
administrator to show up to drop off her
wand and that's when one arrives but the
hot-headed shioi tries to attack him and
misses and gets knocked back and
everyone here realizes that
administrators are strong as hell she
tries to attack mcget and they Clash
weapons causing a sound wave to break
through the building causing some of the
rubble to pin down Aya and yatsamura
think quickly Aya teleports this bad guy
to the roof to meet Serena who cuts it
down instantly killing it and the rest
of the girls then arrive but then they
discover that this administrator is
human which means the rest of them must
be human too whoa talk about a crazy
reveal this administrator Being Human
makes me think that all of the set
administrators were possibly once
magical girls and if that's the case
this could mean that our administrator
Nana might have a weakness that we could
exploit because if we remember Nana only
ever used a signature finger gun as a
method of attack even when Nana met up
with Serena which is weird if you
consider that these people are basically
demigods you think they'd want to use a
bunch of powers because they'd have no
reason not to do so knowing this it
means that we could have taken out an
administrator or the rest of them much
more easily by using shock and awe
tactics or Force concentration against
the single administrator by using
overwhelming power and insane displays
of force in order to knock out the Enemy
by all of us using our magic at the same
time it could be possible that we would
have been able to take it out one
administrator much more easily which
means they aren't as powerful as we
might think and we can use this to
finally take out these administrators
much more easily meanwhile sensing the
battle kyoharu and black hair girl head
to Aya's location but then they get
stopped by another administrator and it
has the power to create multiples of its
body creating an army the girls realize
that they've just fallen into a trap
back on the roof the girls don't have
time to think when Nana shows up and
reveals that they've been set up because
they wanted to lure the girls here all
together and tells them that their
reinforcements will never reach them and
Anana quickly shoots sarana down at
lightning quick speeds but then suddenly
gets a mental message from kyoharu
saying that they need backup and so
broomstick girl goes to save them while
the rest of them stay here to fight and
Nana quickly destroys yatsamura's want
what she thinks quick and triggers a
magic power just as she gets shot down
and Serena's yo-yo chops off one of
Nana's arms Aya and the rest of the
group then realized that yatsamura
sacrificed her life to protect these
girls because they are now in a magical
force field elsewhere yatsumuro suddenly
wakes up in an unknown location confused
Nana here tells her that the King has
selected her to be a new magical girl
site administrator and Nana reveals that
oh by the way the king is actually a
girl and is the most unfortunate girl in
the world when she AKA The Tempest
arrives she will erase all Misfortune
from the World by wiping out most of
humanity and create a new one this giant
eyeball suddenly appears right in front
of her and yatsamura tries to resist
getting turned into administrator but
it's no use back on Earth Aya notices
the magical force field about to be
destroyed she teleports the rest of the
girls away as the force field disappears
and yazamura suddenly wakes up shocking
Aya but she quickly realizes that she's
different and Nana cheers her on and
announces that Yad zamura has been
reborn as a site administrator recruit
but in order to become a full-time one
she will need to consume a lot more
negative energy by killing and stealing
Aya's negative energy meanwhile
broomstick girl finally reaches black
hair girl and saves her from this
monster getting followed they come up
with a plan heading on top to this
building black hair girl uses the full
force of her powers to completely
destroy this administrator back at the
school though Aya tries thrown away from
yatsamura and Nana tells her that the
more negative Aya feels about the world
the more powerful the king will become
Arya thinks fast and teleports behind
yasamura and transports both of them to
the beach they all visited before here
she tries to remind yatsamura of the
good times they had and tells her that
because of her she now loves life it
doesn't feel angry anymore and in
response yatsamura chokes her as is
about to kill her and that's when Aya's
cute and has finally breaks her spell
and Nana then shows up to catch the
final show and that's when these two two
girls surprise Nana and combined their
powers to freeze time and teleport them
right back to near Aya's house where it
all began now trapped by yatsamura's
Powers these two tell Nana that they
will use what little life they have left
to find and save the rest of the magical
girls out there and take down the
Tempest King they unfreeze time and let
Nana get smashed in by this incoming
train then they get happy about life and
even the rest of the magical girl
survive even Serena it's amazing and
everyone here prepares to fight the rest
of the administrators save humanity and
eventually take down the Tempest King
elsewhere though blue-haired cop guy
enters this secret dungeon where he's
keeping glasses guy and he wakes up
afraid and notices all the magical wands
hanging from the wall blue-haired guy
reveals that he's known about him from
the start and he has big plans for him
but says that glass's guy has been a bad
boy and first needs to be punched and
the light goes off and glasses guy
squeals so guys what do you think did
you like the video or didn't you like
the video let us know what you think
about it don't forget to like subscribe
leave a comment down below and as always
don't forget to check out our how to be
playlist